Speaker 2: At this point, it isn't
Speaker 1: clear that anything would actually
shock us about the Trump riots, but we have now
learned something that is sort of shocking about
the attempt to steal the election from Joe Biden
by Donald Trump. There was a PowerPoint. They put
it in writing, this was happening at the highest
Speaker 2: levels of the Trump
administration. The plan was
Speaker 1: extensive. The plan was specific and
detailed, and they actually implemented certain
elements of the plan, of course, not succeeding
in actually stealing the election. If it weren't
totally predictable, it would be surprising.
Speaker 2: But it does
Speaker 1: come as a shock
in terms of the attack on democracy that this
represented. And four years ago, we certainly
would not have imagined that they
Speaker 2: would go this far.
Speaker 1: We knew there was a memo from
a lawyer outlining mechanisms that could
be attempted to try to steal the election
from Joe Biden. But this became a PowerPoint
Speaker 2: presentation, with
Speaker 1: suggestions such as
declare a state of emergency, put in place a
different slate of electors. And all of this
Speaker 2: is relevant because for so
Speaker 1: long, they denied
Speaker 2: the rumors that they were thinking of
Speaker 1: declaring a state
Speaker 2: of emergency, that it was ever
Speaker 1: a discussion. So what this all
is about is a PowerPoint presentation obtained
by the House Committee investigating the Trump
riots. The PowerPoint is called election fraud,
foreign interference and options for January 6th.
And these are options for trying to prevent
Joe Biden from being certified as the winner,
Speaker 2: which of course, he was.
Speaker 1: The PowerPoint was turned over to the
investigative committee by former Trump chief of
Speaker 2: Staff Mark Meadows.
Speaker 1: It is real and it is spectacular.
Here are some slides from it. And of course,
all the rumors were true. They denied
it. All the things we believe they were
Speaker 2: planning, they were indeed planning.
Speaker 1: First slide called options for January
6th lists VP Pence seats Republican
electors over the objections of Dems
in states where fraud occurred.
Speaker 2: We knew they were
planning this, just Mike,
Speaker 1: Pence says,
Speaker 2: because there is fraud in
Speaker 1: Arizona
Speaker 2: instead of ceding the Democratic
Speaker 1: electors. We have an alternate slate
of Republican electors.
Speaker 2: Insane,
insane. Second option VP
Speaker 1: Pence rejects electors
from states where fraud occurred, causing the
election to be decided by the remaining electoral
votes. So the idea there is if you just take off
the table, some of the electors instead of needing
270 now, maybe you only need two, 30 or
Speaker 2: 210 or whatever the idea is.
You take enough states
Speaker 1: off the table that Trump's
actual electors that he did win are more than 50
percent. That was the second option. Third option
VP Pence DeLay's decision to allow for vetting
and counting of legal paper ballots. The idea
being well, they would say a ton of these are
Speaker 2: not legal and throw them out.
Speaker 1: That was a slide for the
coup. Like a book report, but for a coup,
Speaker 2: another slide called recommendations
Speaker 1: actually says on it declare a
national security emergency, claim foreign
interference and control of voting systems.
Speaker 2: Remember, they denied, denied,
Speaker 1: denied that there was even a
vulnerability to foreign actors back in
Speaker 2: 2016. Now, all of a sudden they
want to use it, he wrote, was Let's use
Speaker 1: it ourselves to steal the
election and then third recommendation declare
electronic voting in all states invalid. They
denied they were thinking about this stuff,
and it is on the PowerPoint in another slide
called summary of domestic voter fraud.
Speaker 2: They list all of the
Speaker 1: things that they eventually did trot
out. Now this stuff, they try OK. Double voters.
People voted twice. Dead voters. That one, we
spent a lot of time debunking noncitizen voters.
They can't even register to vote. Fake ballots
Speaker 2: like just a ballot you
Speaker 1: make at home. I guess they list eight
states. They are exactly the states that they
talked about. Michigan, Pennsylvania, Wisconsin,
Speaker 2: Minnesota, Georgia, Nevada,
Speaker 1: Arizona, New Mexico. They
did all of it. This was the game plan.
They tried it. Fortunately, they didn't get away
with it. Now they didn't ultimately try declaring
the national security emergency. Or maybe
Trump did, and someone stopped him. When we
don't know yet. We just have to wait. So
there's a few takeaways here. Confirmed for
the 10th time. They were lying all along
Speaker 2: about what they were planning,
Speaker 1: what they were thinking of,
Speaker 2: what they would be
willing to do, it was lie
Speaker 1: after lie after lie
Speaker 2: confirmation. Not surprising.
Speaker 1: Second,
we were right about this being very serious and
probably something they're going to try again. Now
we all had a good old time laughing at the wacky
stuff, right? Rudy Giuliani's face melting the
hair dye. Sidney Powell visibly perplexed by her
own arguments, you know. Oh OK, I get it. Trump,
the big baby, still won't admit he lost all
of it, but this is not a game. And when I
said last week in my commentary based on an
Speaker 2: article that we talked about,
Speaker 1: the next
Speaker 2: coup is already
Speaker 1: being planned. The first
attempt was practice for the next one.
This is very serious. This is not the last
we've heard from this idea. Now, third and last.
When does the Department of Justice get
involved? Merrick Garland has been very hesitant.
I can understand the reasons why he might
Speaker 2: feel that
it would not
Speaker 1: maybe be good
to get involved in this. But how does the
Speaker 2: DOJ justify not getting
Speaker 1: involved
Speaker 2: when every
single fact is so utterly insane and dangerous?
Speaker 1: That's the question that remains,
Speaker 2: and we can't
Speaker 1: put our guard down, even for a second.